right now it feels like there's this war
against workers
and the Liberals are using the Bank of
Canada to blame people's wages
for inflation
wages aren't even keeping up with
inflation
people are doing everything right but
still falling behind
unlike their paychecks they see big
corporations profits going up twice as
fast as inflation
and they know that's greed inflation
and of course Justin Paul Justin Trudeau
and Pierre polio won't say a word about
multi-billion dollar companies
breaking in massive profits their
billionaire CEO friends are making
record profits Lobos alone has profits
that have increased by 29 percent
gross machines the corporate chains
across this country are raking in
millions in extra windfall profits every
week
by charging Canadians 40 dollars for a
pack of chicken
they're using inflation as cover to pad
their profits and it's not just
groceries it's everything we buy
it's our mortgage rent
cell phone bills last month when we
proposed the idea of again putting a
windfall tax on the wealthiest
corporations profiting off the backs of
people he dismissed the idea as
simply too simplistic
a windfall tax that could be used as a
disincentive to gouge Shoppers he said
no it's too Simplicity can't do it
seriously
other governments across the world have
stood up to corporate greed with the
windfall tax including the United
Kingdom even under a conservative
government because it works the truth is
Justin Trudeau doesn't want a windfall
tax or penalties for gouging consumers
or even proper competition laws he's
never going to make them pay what theyo
and he's never going to stop big
corporations for making billions of
dollars exploiting and off the backs of
workers
we learned this week that one of the
firms in Justin Trudeau's Inner Circle
McKenzie and company has been handed 101
million dollars by the Trudeau
government
101 million dollars that could have put
over a thousand more nurses on the front
lines for a year
and we all know that Government after
government has pulled the same nonsense
when conservatives are in power they
give their insiders contracts when the
Liberals in power their friends get
contracts
the prime minister's Inner Circle
includes corporations like McKinsey and
the Loblaw's Empire and it shows
the reality is every victory for real
Canadians Dental Care anti-scap
legislation bigger GST rebates these
were things that liberals and
conservatives fought against
until the NDP forced Mr Trudeau
without saying but of course Pierre
pauliev is not the answer just last
just last week
I mean if you needed any more evidence
he went to Winnipeg to spend time with
health privatization pushers the
frontier Center
the frontier Center does sadly and
pretty seriously they have denied that
residential schools hurt children
they deny that climate crisis is human
made
empirical I have chose that group in
particular to go to and to speak in
front of Pierre pauliev plans to cut
your pension and your social safety net
and who benefits from that who benefits
from cutting CPP in EI not you not
workers
Rich CEOs and their companies will take
in more than half a billion dollars away
from your pensions and add it to their
profits instead more bonuses for the
very biggest bosses he's here for them
he will cut what you need in order to
give them what they want from your
pension to your health care
we envision a Canada where Healthcare is
ready for you when and where you need it
we're nurses and doctors and Frontline
healthcare workers are respected and
there's enough of them so you don't have
to wait
[Applause]